foreign
s a year as a nation we return to this
topic this great question where should
parents be allowed to bring their kids
what parts of society should families
with young children have access to now
I'm not talking about the debate over
children at things like drag shows which
is not a debate at all they just simply
shouldn't be there the problem with with
bringing your child to a drag show is
that the content of the show is not
appropriate for the child it is for the
child's sake that we object to the child
being there what I'm talking about is
the debate that centers around the needs
and preferences of other adults in what
context is your child's presence going
to be an unfair burden on other adults
predictably it's always the childless
adults who have very strong feelings
about this subject and this week one
such childless adult went viral with her
video demanding that parents stop
bringing their kids to bars breweries
and potentially dozens of other places
as well this video has 150 000 likes so
apparently a great many people agree
with her and here's what she says watch
2023 parents are my favorite like we're
not just bringing our kids we're making
ourselves at home
now you can consider me biased because
I'm aggressively opposed to the idea of
having children for myself that is
but if you take your child to a place
where they are actively engaged in the
process of producing or processing an
age-restricted substance alcohol
marijuana cigarettes whatever if you
take your child into one of these places
you are objectively and unequivocally
the Apple in that situation it's a
non-negotiable
it's there's nothing to debate you are
told in that situation not only because
your child just doesn't belong there but
because you were actively making the
experience worse for every other adult
present
you don't want me to curse around your
child you don't want me to talk about
who I was done over the weekend you
don't want me to have an adult
conversation around your child Here's a
thought stop bringing your children into
bars and breweries
there's literally nothing for them to do
there they're bored in yourself thank
you so much
okay now because this point of view is
widely shared by other bitter childless
spinsters it's worth responding to in
some detail and we're going to leave
aside the irony that this woman would
almost certainly tell us that children
shouldn't be allowed in places that
serve alcohol unless that place is a
drag show I highly highly doubt that
this person agrees with our lawn here in
Tennessee for example Banning children
from attending sexualized performances
I highly doubt she agrees with that but
we will not allow that glaring issue to
Sidetrack us there are too many other
glaring issues to deal with
so first
you don't want children in places that
produce or process an age-restricted
item and you then list bars as one of
those places which means that by process
you apparently mean sell and if that's
the case then you have also banned
children from nearly every restaurant
every plane every gas station most
grocery stores every Pharmacy every
convenience store every Best Buy or
Walmart that sells R-rated Blu-rays Etc
you've basically banned children from
all of society which I understand is a
feature not a bug as far as you are
concerned but that is what you're
talking about second
you say that you know I as a parent that
I don't want you talking about who you
were having sex with over the weekend
because my kids might hear you and it's
true that I don't want my kids to hear
that gross conversation but I I don't
want to hear it either even if I don't
have my kids with me okay you shouldn't
be going around having conversations
like that loud enough that any stranger
of any age can hear it actually it's
better just to not have that
conversation at all
see part of the miscommunication here is
that you think that we don't want you to
act like a gross vulgar Pig because our
kids are with us but you're only half
right we also just don't want you to act
like that at all period
so you don't have a problem with kids
you have a problem apparently with being
a civilized human being
you say that cussing loudly and talking
about your revolting sexual exploits is
an adult conversation but this only
reflects the very unfortunate way in
which the word adult in our culture has
come to mean profane and crass
that's not what it really means or
should mean the kind of conversation
you're talking about it's not an adult
conversation and the behavior you want
to engage in is not adult Behavior it's
actually childish not in content but in
the fact that you apparently have a
problem conforming yourself to a basic
standard of conduct
ironically you don't want to be around
children because you are childish
it's not that children prevent you from
acting adult it's that they interfere
with your ability to act like a child
so it's not that you you want there to
be no children at the brewery you just
want to be yourself the only child at
the brewery
third I'm I am biased also I admit uh
you're lonely and single I have a family
and six kids but it's not just my bias
talking when I tell you this
if you hate children and don't want to
be around them at all anywhere
then you are the in the
situation and in life generally it is
not okay to hate children that's just
like not an okay opinion to have
you can have it can't stop you but it's
not an okay thing to think you shouldn't
think that
it reflects a profound character flaw in
yourself it reveals a deep sickness in
your soul
of all the people to reflexively despise
children are the absolutely absolute
least deserving
kids are innocent naive energetic fun
it's really going to wear on the nerves
sometimes but at least they have a valid
excuse whenever they act annoying and
disruptive
they're kids they're still learning
their brains aren't fully developed
you on the other hand are an obnoxious
irritating jerk without any of those
built-in excuses
you don't want to be around kids I don't
want to be around people like you but we
live in a society together so I know
that I have to deal with such encounters
just like you do
it's funny to me that our culture
pretends to oppose bigotry and yet the
one group of people that it's socially
acceptable to openly despise aside from
heterosexual white men is children we
have no problem with someone simply
stating that they don't like kids and
don't want to be around them and yet if
I said the same thing about any other
group
it would be considered horribly bigoted
meanwhile again kids are the least
deserving of that treatment out of all
the groups on Earth
if you're going to have an instinctive
revulsion towards any group
kids should be the very last on that
list
but the good news for me anyway
is that your Hang-Ups and your
bitterness are your problem
that's why I will gladly walk into any
environment with my six kids we just
went to a restaurant on Sunday and uh
and I and I will think nothing of the
dirty looks we get and we get a lot of
them okay when we go in there with our
circus and parents of large families
they they know these looks very well
people do not disguise their disgust and
reflexive contempt as soon as we walk in
the door
our presence is already a burden on
everyone else even before my kids have
opened their mouths
it's like they don't even we don't even
get a chance to prove how well behaved
my kids are public because as soon as
they're there everyone's looking oh my
God look at this
and some parents of large families are
are bothered by this dream but I'm not
I'm really not I will come and sit right
next to you with my school bus load of
kids and if you don't like it that's
your problem you can glare all you want
I don't care you you can ask for the
check and leave if you want we've seen
that too doesn't matter it doesn't
bother me
it's your problem my family is allowed
to participate in society same as you my
children aren't going to stay locked up
in the house until they turn 18 for fear
that their presence might be an
encumbrance on any resentful losers we
happen to come across
Society should welcome and celebrate
families
okay it should go out of its way to
include us as much as possible that's
what a healthy Society does
in a healthy Society people are happy
when they see families with young happy
kids this should make you happy to see
that
if it doesn't again there is something
wrong with you
you know as families with young kids we
make the world younger more vibrant more
beautiful More Alive we ensure the very
future of the human species what the
hell are you doing besides gossiping at
the bar about sexual Conquest that let's
be honest you're probably making up
that's what you should ask yourself
well I order my kids some chicken
tenders from the kids menu and you glare
at us
secretly resenting the fact that we have
the life you want but will never have
and that's why you're canceled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there